Whether you are a Christian or not,...
...visiting the Judean Desert and the Dead Sea in Israel...
...would be a once in a lifetime experience.
The Bible mentions that the Judean Desert was where the Holy Spirit...
...led Jesus into the wilderness.
This place is a harsh landscape...
...where you can experience an austere and inhospitable wilderness.
Floating in the Dead Sea is a photo opportunity...
...and an experience not to be missed.
How about relaxing in the mineral-rich black mud?
Because the Dead Sea is 420 meters below sea level,...
...ultraviolet radiation is low and the sun is safe.
The high concentration of oxygen in the air...
...and the minerals in the water make this a very healthy place, indeed.
In addition, if you want to enjoy...
...the spectacular views of the desert and Dead Sea,...
...there is a cable car to take you up to Herod's Palace.